[Musique]
notre ca ce soir avec Claire Bolduc
préfet de la MRC de Thémis scamang et
Jacinthe Eve Harel spécialiste en
développement des affaires mesdames
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir le ministre Jean
Boulay a annoncé donc le ministre du
Travail a annoncé qu'il va fixer l'âge
minimal pour travailler à 14 ans dès le
mois de septembre il y aura quelques
exceptions comme garder des enfants
livrer des journaux par exemple ou être
moniteur dans des camps de joie
j'asseyais d'abord qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de la proposition est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord ben je pense que c'est
malheureux qu'on empêche des jeunes de
13 ans par exemple qui sont qui
voudraient changer quelques heures
devant leurs écrans pour expérimenter le
marché du travail et expérimenter aussi
l'épargne les bienfaits de l'épargne et
je pense que c'est pas au gouvernement
de se substituer au jugement des
entrepreneurs et des parents et des
enfants ok très clair qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez
moi je suis une mère et une grand-mère
de huit petits enfants je pense qu'on
est face à un débat de société où on a
vu les jeunes sur le marché du travail
comme la solution à la pénurie main
d'oeuvre et se débat devrait se faire de
façon saine pour chercher à faire le
plus d'équilibres possible qu'on les
fixé l'âge de travail à 14 ans
m'apparaît correct c'est vrai que
peut-être qu'un enfant de 13 ans ou un
jeune de 13 ans ou un enfant peut avoir
une meilleure maturité et vouloir
découvrir autre chose il peut progresser
quand même un peu pour pouvoir le faire
mais clairement on est face à un débat
de société où nos valeurs sont
confrontées aux besoins de main d'oeuvre
ça doit permettre de générer des
équilibres on a vu quand même des
reportages où il y a des jeunes de 13
ans puis parfois de 11 ans ou de 12 ans
qui prêtent mais forte sur le marché du
travail pour pallier à la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre est-ce que je synthèse
c'est une solution à la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre de faire travailler des jeunes
c'est une des solutions c'est pas pour
ça qu'on permet à nos jeunes de
travailler s'il le souhaite c'est une
des solutions mais c'est certain que si
on met une limite à 14 ans on va se
retrouver avec une pression à la hausse
sur les salaires et ça se retrouvera sur
nos factures comme consommateur et en
plus de tous les désavantages là que ça
a pour les enfants qui sont concernés
par ça est-ce que ce projet de loi est
une mauvaise nouvelle pour les
employeurs
en fait je le répète le travail la main
d'oeuvre jeune ne doit pas être la
solution à tous les problèmes de main
d'oeuvre à tous les problèmes de pénurie
de main d'oeuvre je pense que les jeunes
peuvent contribuer clairement à être
associé au marché du travail il faut que
ce soit en équilibre avec les besoins
des jeunes eux-mêmes on doit laisser les
jeunes les enfants et les jeunes passer
à travers les étapes de la jeunesse et
devenir des travailleurs je pense qu'ils
peuvent avoir un apprentissage mais on
doit respecter leur capacité à le faire
on doit respecter les cheminements qui
sont les leurs au moment où ils le font
question de débat de société question de
valeur question surtout d'équilibre
est-ce qu'il faut est-ce qu'il faudrait
accorder des exceptions puisqu'on s'en
va vers le 14 ans jacintheve est-ce
qu'on doit
donc se dire qu'il faut des exceptions
faut penser aux petits petits employeurs
qui ont pas beaucoup d'employés dans
certaines circonstances qui ont de la
difficulté em du personnel on aurait un
amendement et on changerait le 14 ans
pour un 13 ou un 12 mais ça c'est
l'idéal mais sinon bien sûr des
exceptions mais ça finira plus les
exceptions il y a tellement de
situations et chaque région chaque
industrie possède ses propres
particularités et au bout du compte
c'est à chaque famille et à chaque
parent aussi de prendre ses décisions là
dans chaque coin unique à chaque
entreprise aussi donc les mesures
exceptionnelles oui s'il le faut
absolument mais c'est pas l'idéal
l'esprit du projet de loi c'est aussi
d'assurer un contexte de travail qui est
sain qui est sécuritaire pour les jeunes
la CNA SST constatait d'ailleurs en juin
2022 une hausse de 36% des accidents de
travail chez les moins de 16 ans
est-ce que est-ce que c'est correct de
faire travailler les jeunes quand on
voit cette situation là claire est-ce
que c'est suffisant pour sensibiliser
les employeurs à cet enjeu là
moi j'aimerais qu'on se rappelle que la
question de la sécurité du travail
sécuritaire c'est une grande
responsabilité de tous les employeurs
pour tous leurs employés mais on est
face à de jeunes des jeunes personnes
qui n'ont pas nécessairement développé
des réflexes la capacité d'anticipation
pour faire face à des situations dans le
milieu de travail en conséquence les
mesures qui vont permettre d'assurer
leur sécurité dans quel qu'emplois
qu'ils exerceront elles doivent être de
façon très très attentive permettent une
très grande sécurité de ces jeunes
travailleurs-là c'est une question de
leur donner confiance dans les milieux
de travail c'est aussi une question de
les respecter dans leur capacité et dans
leur développement mais les employeurs
ont cette responsabilité là de base il y
a aussi la question du décrochage je
s'intègre à elle si qui touche beaucoup
les garçons majoritairement le ministre
dit qu'il veut établir des barèmes très
stricts comme limiter à 17 heures le
nombre d'heures de travail par semaine
pour ceux qui ont l'obligation de
fréquenter l'école parce qu'elle a 14
ans faut aller à l'école c'est l'école
d'abord est-ce que pas un danger de
décrochage c'est si on permet aux jeunes
de travailler ben 17h ça semble être
tout à fait normal ça semble être
raisonnable comme limite de toute façon
probablement que la majorité des parents
qui ont des jeunes c'est autour de ça 12
15 17h maximum là qu'on autorise nos
enfants à aller travailler nos jeunes
aller travailler donc c'est une mesure
qui me semble raisonnable est-ce que ça
prenait absolument une loi pour dire aux
gens comment être raisonnable
ouais ben je sais pas je présume que si
on fait une loi claire c'est parce qu'il
y a un problème non
tout à fait c'est la loi sert à donner
les balises les principales balises qui
vont entourer le travail des jeunes dans
notre société la loi ne répond pas et ne
règle pas tous les problèmes alors ça
doit être un travail qui se fait de
concert avec les travailleurs mais aussi
avec les employeurs avec les parents il
y avait que les jeunes eux-mêmes dans
leur contexte de travail dans ce
contexte-là la loi donne des grandes
lignes puis oui je pense qu'on en a
besoin mais on a aussi besoin de
réfléchir comme société à comment on
peut réorganiser et restructurer les
environnements et les milieux de travail
si je peux me permettre mon fils à 13
ans il travaille et aujourd'hui
m'annonçait qu'il y a eu son cinquième
héritage à l'école alors chaque
situation est particulière et c'est aux
parents déterminé qu'est-ce qui est
mieux pour eux ça lui apporter une
discipline de vigne discipline
personnelle il s'est mis comme objectif
100% d'épargne et il dit qu'il va avoir
sa mise de fond pour la première maison
à l'âge de 20 ans il y a fait ses
calculs il va découvrir l'intérêt de
composés alors c'est tout ça qui est en
train de s'exposer à l'âge de 13 ans et
sans difficulté pour son école cela
étant dit c'est pas le cas tous les
jeunes c'est pour ça qu'il faut regarder
soit par Coop et chacun son histoire
personnelle moi j'ai travaillé dans mon
enfance beaucoup j'ai passé le journal
j'étais plongeur et puis j'ai travaillé
dans un clip vidéo et je me rappelle que
je travaillais à 12 ou 13 ans
et à un moment de notre jeunesse quand
on grandit on se pose la question je
travaille en ce moment est-ce que je
continue à travailler est-ce que je
continue d'aller à l'école pour
travailler où est-ce que il y a quand
même des questions fondamentales qui
viennent sur la possibilité de décrocher
parce qu'on travaille il y a une
influence du travail que nous occupons à
ce moment-là de notre Vie Claire
n'est-ce pas
tout à fait et c'est la question
d'équilibre qu'on doit rechercher parce
que oui les jeunes font un apprentissage
intéressant de règles de vie de règles
de société de fonctionnement ou de
responsabilisation quand il travaille
quand il occupent un emploi cela dit
c'est pas tout le monde que les mêmes
capacités c'est pas tout le monde que
les mêmes le même environnement
disons-le dans ce contexte là le respect
de chacun moi je suis absolument
d'accord avec la synthèse faut pouvoir
respecter chacun des enfants dans son
fonctionnement maintenant au-delà de
tout ça on doit réfléchir vraiment comme
société ce qu'on veut faire mes enfants
travaillaient sur la ferme chez nous sur
ma ferme quand ils étaient plus jeunes
ils ont pas toujours apprécié ils ont
pas toujours aimé ça mais ils sont
toujours
oui tout à fait
il faut vraiment réfléchir à revoir moi
je propose vraiment qu'on fasse un
amendement au 14 ans parce que le danger
qu'on a aussi c'est que les jeunes
rendus à 14 ans après avoir passé deux
étés puis on y a des jeunes aussi qui
vont avoir leur 14 ans l'automne là donc
ils m'ont perdent un été il y a des
jeunes qui vont perdre l'intérêt aussi
parce qu'ils vont avoir découvert ce que
c'est que de passer l'été sur leurs
écrans et on leur permet pas de
découvrir la discipline et les bonnes
habitudes vous êtes très intéressante
une belle discussion merci Claire merci
je t'aime merci bonne soirée pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI